welcome to this Hands-On course where
you will learn how to create a Google
Drive clone harnessing the power of
nextjs typescript Tailwind CSS and fire
Blas 9 dive deep into the Synergy of
these Technologies as Nishant Singh
guides you step by step to build a
feature-rich responsive and scalable
cloud storage application Nishant is a
popular instructor on our Channel and
I'm sure you'll learn a ton from this
course hey guys Nishant so let's learn
how to build a Google Drive clone using
nextjs typescript Tailwind CSS and
Firebase along with next o so first
let's sign up to our application we will
see GitHub sign up we are now signed in
and the folder name is called root so we
have the option to add a file or add a
folder so let me do a folder first we
can name this as
folder three click
create and we now have a folder three
here so if I open this we will be on
this page and we don't have any files or
folder inside the folder three so we can
add a file if I create or if I choose a
file let me choose any file let's say
this photos or any photo not the private
but fine you will see a bar of progress
here with with my image at the top it is
the let's say my get image so if I add a
picture it will be it will reflect in
here we can also addite a folder so
let's say
nested folder click create and it will
be in here so we can add Ned folder
inside another folder open this we can
add a file inside so let me let me add
this file now so it will auto
automatically upload it and once the
file upload completes the image will be
here that we can open in a new tab in
Google Chrome see if I go back we don't
have the image in here because they are
private to the folder so if I come to
the root we are having these files come
to folder three we are having these
files come to next folder we are having
this file so if I go back in folder one
we we have this folder one of next
folder one and the image click it we
have this files with my file folder
basically what I want to say is we can
create a folder inside a folder inside
another folder and the same is true with
files as well so let's learn how to
build this application using the S
Technologies so let me create or let me
just first tell you what is that I have
on screen so it is a thing called T3
stack which is basically a combination
of nextjs with typescript along with
some other things that I will show you
now so if I open Terminal here and if I
just do 1 second if I do npm create T3
app at theate latest enter let's name
the app as Drive clone or 2.0 we can say
Drive
2.0 enter we will use typescript so here
are the things that I told you about
like we have next to and authentication
library then we have
Tailwind we also have trpc and Prisma
but we will not use them so okay let me
just add Prisma in order to use next Ro
just press enter now okay we don't need
a Depot for now so let me skip it yes I
want to done and can install so don't
skip it and let me just zoom the screen
we want import LSS like let's say at the
rate okay it's not working so just okay
we can say at the rate enter so it is
installing this dependencies so we can
wait for it meanwhile let me go over to
this website called
Tailwind it was there's a library called
for Tailwind I don't remember the name
so it is I
think let me see Tailwind
library for UI let me see yes this was
Dy UI I forgot the name so I am sorry
for that maybe not so this is the
library that we will install later which
is called d y basically it is a I can
say rapper for Tailwind where we can
simply use the Tailwind glasses here so
so we can just go to I I can just go to
customize component or components for
example if you want to use a button for
Tailwind we can simply use class of or
class name of BTN or if I want colors
like TR secondary or outlined we can use
BN accent BN outline or rounded or full
PX and whatnot so it's done now let me
open the folder
and we also have to do npx Prisma DB
push to push the Prisma schema to the
database then we can run npm run div and
if I want to push the repo to GitHub we
can simply push it so let me open this
drive clone where it is Drive 2.0 so let
me do npm I okay it's done so let me
push the first let me run the
application so we can say npm run Dev
let me collapse this and it is on Local
Host 3,000 let me open this so we need
to go to the EnV file and here you will
have Discord client ID and client
secret so we should have a sign up
button but it is not here so I think
what we can do is just go to Source this
page is called
Pages app TSX
H index. TSX yes so let me push the
schema to Prisma using this command
called npx Prisma D push it has been
pushed so now let me go
to this Library called Next
o I think we have to create a button and
so on things like that in order to use
next so we have installed this if I go
to package of package.json file you will
see we will have Zod react next and this
kind of stuff now let me also add this
Library called dii using this command
enter we also have to import this plugin
into our module. exports in D.C config
dots we have plugins we just need to add
this here isi so close
this and close the terminal close the
terminal yes now if you open let me
close the 33 app do
G so what can we do let me open use or
customize component so we can just copy
any
button let me copy the button come over
to let's say what was the file name
index. TSX I think the screen is screen
was too big now it was too big now it's
fine so let me clear the entire things
from here like these
things and this link the D as well and
just add the button here just make this
as class name not class so if I now
check give it ready fret we will have
the button from that is UI like this
button so we can add different types of
we can say button class names like BTN
primary after BTM or BTN so we'll see
this so let me rename this
to sign in or what we can do is create a
folder here called components in the
source folder okay no not such we need
we need a folder called
components don't let scare don't don't
let it scare you it is just
a uh what can we
say it is just a next
application yes make a function
component and then just add a button
that we want to add like one two or
three
whatever so this should be class
name and this thing that we are having
bet and primary we'll receive it from
props so we can say button class then
let me copy the button class add it in
here so we have to first replace the
codes with back tck one second yes also
wrap it in a what is it
clyra and then he use this as a variable
using this but we have to create a
instance or prop so make a folder head
called
instance or maybe in sorry not instance
what I am typing interface
sorry then let me make simple index. TSX
file only one file where we will have
all the interfaces so let's say we have
a interface
called button
interface or just say button so in the
button we are having button class
which is a if you hover this it is not
giving us any type so if I come over
here then import this button as common
component using at theate component
button and we can just replace this
button here so we have to pass the thing
here called BR class BN class or yes so
we can just make it a string so yes this
will be a string so we have to add this
in the interface that this is the class
or of button class it is a
string because we're passing a string
here so we have to pass let's say Bain
primary this class now we have to just
add as a string we have added it now let
me use this prop or interface in
here like this save this as well and we
will
have this we can also pass a text or say
title title will be let's say sign up so
we have to pass title in here as
well so as props I mean get it here then
replace one with title so that it will
become or it will it becomes
Dynamic then we have to add title in
here as well which is a string
also like this save all these files and
if I come to the app we will see a
button called sign up which is from
Tailwind
now if I check this next o we have
installed it we have to add the provider
in the next o file which is in the O so
come to API we have next o here we are
having no things or nothing so let me
export this const and remove one second
export default next o Au options so we
have Au options say this the thing is
what is individual declaration in merge
declaration blah blah
blah export cons export default why
don't I just copy the entire code base
and paste it yes
so okay the thing is we are previously
we were importing Au options but now we
need geta provider in order to add it
yes I mean we have to change the inputs
here we are having G provider with
client Iden client secret so if I go to
GitHub now let me go to GitHub and just
go to settings here where the
settings okay where is
it where do I find settings in here yes
it is here
settings go to developer settings on the
left
panel here we will have o o o
apps let me create a new O app called
let's say Drive
2.0 let's add the homepage URL which is
this Local Host 3,000 and such add it we
can say this is a drive clone we need
call back URL to just paste the GitHub I
mean this URL called Local Host 3,000
click registered application we will
have client ID here so we can just copy
C ID and if you see that we we are
having the GitHub ID in this process.
file here so it is Discord basically not
GitHub so let me first add the ID and
replace this with GitHub client ID or
GitHub ID so we can do this then the
second thing is GitHub secret so just
add this one here fine so now if I just
come in the gith or section we need to
generate a new client secret so click
the button here called generate a new
client
secret let me give my password please
don't see it confirm
this and we are having the secret here
so let me copy the secret and now paste
this in the EnV file save this
and we need to what is the issue
here uh type string or undefined and is
not assignable to type of string come to
interface create an interface here
called let's say gabo so in this let me
add client ID and client secret the both
are strings so client ID next is client
secret this will be a string as well
save them both now this type or the
interface will be in the GitHub provider
in angle brackets like this so we have
initialized geta provider now the next
step in order to use it is to if I come
here in the where file app do TSX we are
having component page props and such
these things okay component is wrapped
in the syst provider fine if I come all
all the way
down so we need to use use session let
me try to import this things in the file
called pages in here use session sign in
and sign out from next s react okay the
next step is we need to destructure data
and session from this use
session and so we have a button here we
have a button here yes on click the
button we can simply sign in or sign out
so let me try this let me just hook this
button on this button component the
button will receive let me close this
the button will receive one more prop
called
onclick and the when the button is on
clicked the function that we are having
Here sign in will run save this we need
to add type here which will be a
function which return return type of
void so we can just try this and see
what happens now if I click sign up we
are seeing this page yes sign in with
GitHub click this let me authorize this
nan6 app from dive 2.0 but I don't think
we have subscribed so what I can do is
just do a console look of the data one
second not data session we can just go
to console in here we are having an
object with the
username image and the name as well so
the image is I think from GitHub this
image that I am having so we can use
that okay it expires on this time stamp
that I cannot read properly so what we
can
do if session
exists let me do it here I mean if
session is here it
means we cannot log in again we can just
log out so let me not put this here let
me use session here so we can simply do
if s exists in this case we will use a
button for sign out not sign in so let
me add a button here another one here
and then close it or delete this so this
should be sign up sorry sign not sign in
sign out and this will be sign up so let
me just do sign out in here and this
will be sign up if session is true or if
is having some data this will be shown
else this will be shown now we can
remove the console log from here and
click sign out so immediately we will
see sign up button here now click it
again we can click sign in with GitHub
and we are now signed in let also have
the username so if I bring my session in
the
console so we are having an object here
from the what is this next thought where
we have the image and the name so let me
remove or just here let me add welcome
let me add the name so the name will be
let's say session do
username yes now we'll see welcome
Nishant Kumar here but this is not
looking as a drive so we can just
command this out for now and let me move
the button at the top right here that
where I am having the curser let me
close what settings so let me move that
button at the top what we can
do create one second what I'm thinking
is so let me create
or we need to move the button that fine
but let me create a component
first before that let me create a folder
called common let moove the button in
the common folder that we know that
button is a folder that or button is a
component that can be used at different
places so we have done that now let me
create a folder or file in
the uh components called we can
say home.
TSX make it a functional
component but will it clash with index I
guess not let's see save home let me
import the home component in the pages
so
import home from components home I think
it is clashing so we can just make this
as home component
now import this from this and let me
render it out in this div save and they
will see home let me move session in
here in the home
component so we need these things which
are data and session from you session so
let me have them here or let me create a
hook for this a common or a custom hook
let me make a folder called hooks
in here we can say use session. TSX not
t not tsz
TSX so what we need in here we need this
things called U session sign in and sign
out add them we need data and this
session also add it but we need to make
a function so export const use session
okay we need another function sorry so
this is already defined from the next
use session so we can
say what we can say use fetch session
okay let's change the name to this in
here what do we
need we need these things okay just save
this and return this div which is the
button so we need the button here so we
can say import button from this route in
the use
session now or all of the errors are now
going on B so let me remove the entire
div in here let me import use fetch
session from use session in the hooks
folder then
return or let me do this we need the use
session so let me destructure let's say
this what can we call this
jsx okay I guess let me just move them
in here in the home and just have sign
out and sign in
function in here remove U session so we
also need the button so just cut it from
here and add the button in here so we
need the session from here so let me
return only the session like this so
this is returning the session as an OP
object so we have to D structure it we
let
session equals to use fetch session and
now everything will work out so as I
said that we have to make this at the
very top right so give it a class name
called let's
say uh or BTN but we need to create a
styling file so why don't we install SAS
npm i s SS it's done
now let me create a file here called or
one thing I have done wrong is make a
folder first called home let me move the
home to TSX in the home folder we need
to import
updates so do this save and save here as
well so here we don't need this
sessions let me make it clear and this
as well we don't need them so we have
installed SAS make a file here called
index. t
SX and in the pages we are having home
and home so let's change that just
rename this as index. TSX okay this
should be not TSX this should be
scss now home should be index. TSX
because we don't need to add duplicate
Imports like this like home slome we can
just have home and home will render the
index file now in the let me put this
CSS or scss file in the home so
import index.
scss now we need to use all button class
name in the index.
scss so this should be okay what is the
problem Global CSS cannot be imported in
the files other than custom CSS okay I
think this CS I forgot to mention that
this nextjs uses o sorry it uses
uh CSS module so if I come to index. TSX
sorry app. TSX we are
having this thing called okay we don't
have it here in the global. CSS we are
having come to
index so let's say that we are having
class names here okay okay what we have
to do just come to this and let me make
this as o BTN now now copy this come to
the homepage so we will not use class
names like this we can do what do
Styles
dot this Orban so we have to import
Styles so where do I import it
from let me check
Pages app.
TSX let me check any Styles file like
global. CSS we are having these kind of
of
things so I am forgetting how do this
how does this
work let me check on Google so what we
have to do is let me just remove this
index
import name the file to let's say home
do module.
scss now let me import the file
here so we will do import Styles styes
from from this file now we will have no
errors fine because this is how we do
styling in nextjs using modules so in
the OR BN let me give a position of
absolute top 20
PX right 20 PX as well so that it sticks
on the this position so we will have
sign on button but we will not show it
because we have to show the image of the
user so if I just do a
console.log of
session we can have the image in here
that I previously
mentioned so it is having
user so we can say do user do image so
it will give it the link of the image so
we can use that so let me turn this into
an image tag first comment it out and
then make a image so SCE which will be
equal
to this session do user.
image so we can just add them user does
not exist type of never what is this
thing here so we will have the image
okay sign out okay we have done it wrong
this should be not here this should be
in here sorry okay
save string null undefined is is not
assignable to string
undefined okay we need to create a type
for this
image so or we can just make as string
here it will go away simple now we have
this big image so let's shorten it give
it a class name here called styles do
proile IMG or
image now we can use this profile
IMG in here sorry this
only width let's make 100 pixels then
border radius 50% to make it round it
like this let me also throw cursor as
pointer
fine now this should be
not in a home page we can just add them
in a component for top
part so a folder called top
bar in here make a file called index do
TSX and one for the home module I mean
The Styling module so we can say top bar
do
module do
scss now let me shift these things this
entire div in here but why don't I shift
entire home function in here just change
the name of of Home component
to top bar so we don't okay we need sign
out let me just leave it now let me
import this component in here the Stop
Bar first let me name the styles of the
class name then import
the uh what is it the top bar
import top bar from this
component and simply then render it out
here like this let me remove console log
the button and just the button so top
bar is here and we have a problem here
cannot
resolve home. mod scss so this should be
top bar modu scss in the top bar we can
just have these things
paste Let me refresh cannot resolve
home. module Doss in the okay let me
check in
the top bar here okay so we have to save
it as well save and it will be
fine so remove console log and if I
click the home we should sign out so in
the image we can say on click sign out
okay what is this issue let me just have
an call back function I
think
yes so if I click it we will be signed
out this should a function just not
a click it now we are signed up or
signed out click it again and we can
sign in using GitHub so basically you
can use GitHub or let's say Facebook or
Google anything let me come to next
R here we'll have let's say get started
we can have anything here we like if I
come one second if I come to Providers
we have all these things like apple
atlassian o
zero battle net and whatnot so we can
have Google here as well we just need to
have Google client ID and secret from I
think uh gcd Google client developer
tools and whatever it is so we have done
this perfect let me close the things
that we don't need like interface top
bar module we don't need for now also
closes so we do need the
home
and this we don't need so remove use
fetch
session we have pages in the pages we
are having the home component in the
home we are having top bar for now so
what else we can do now here is create
the body for adding files in the fire
store yeah so let's create a component
for this thing what thing like uploading
a file or a folder first so in the pages
we have the home page called index which
is rendering the home component F so in
the components let me make a folder
called we can say
upload
files let make an index. TSX file in
here a functional component let's make
the name as
upload files but okay let me also get it
in the home
dot uh home component so we can say
import home
from 1 second what I'm doing this upload
files I
mean from upload
files then render it
here so I will see upload files here
fine now we need to come to this file
and just make a I mean folder first make
a file for this styling so upload do
module
dot
scss so import this end
the
and first okay let me know
styles
from this
one now just add a class here and we can
say Styles
dot what should we name this let's say
upload me in here let me come and just
do margin
zero this will not work so I guess let
me come to Styles Global okay what else
or where else do we have
stylings so we need to reset all the
Styles so we can just say body
margin zero okay this is coming in the
center we it in the not at the center we
can have it like at the top
so what we can do for that is we have
styles then we have the one second where
else do we have styles what if I remove
these things it will be like this okay
what if frame of Tailwind base no
Tailwind
utilities yes now it's fine so remove
Tailwind utilities because this will
just remove the class names for margin
and part padding so remove this as well
because we don't need that so here we
also didn't need margin or maybe we need
20 pixels in order to spread it like
here
so what we can do is we have upload
files let me add a button here so okay
if I if I add a button yes let's add a
button so we can import button from
common button just render it in here
this button will take a title so let's
say add a file and one more it was
saying one more property let me over and
see it is the class name so let me come
to interface and make the button class
as optional Ono the on click
event yes so we have add a file also let
me add the class name so if I come to
this let me try
bet primary again let's just make this
as our custom button class so we can say
class name equals to this okay what is
the name it is BN class fine save and it
is now in purple we have add a file one
more we need for a folder so we can say
add
a folder or basically create a
folder we need these things let me add a
margin among them so we can say M2 here
as well no it is not working so I guess
make P2 padding no still not
working so we are having B class that is
just taking okay in the BN Primary in
the button let me come to
button we have the button okay what if I
add what is the key for margin here so
let me just check button we have here we
are having all the buttons fine if I
come down invo success and so on we have
responsive button we have white button
we have these kind of things but we need
to check how to give margin among them
so let's search anywhere what is the key
for margin in the layout and
neography so if I come down somewhere to
find margin if I search margin will I
get it so this should be M2 like this
should
be M3 or M to but it is not
working so let me make a file here for
button so this should
be first let me make a folder for button
move this inside
yes and now make a file for scss so
button
dot module do
scss so in here first let me import this
import uh styles from this file now just
have the
Styles and basically we can first do
Styles dot some class name in here so we
can
say common let me add margin as say 20
pixels so we can use the common BN in
here like this but no not this common
BN but the thing is this is uh okay
number is not assignable type of
string common B this should
be like this in camel
case now we can just remove this add
this and if I cut this and paste it
inside of this string like here this
should work but it is not so let me
check here sty upload menu okay if I
remove the entire thing in here add this
it is working what if I
add one more curly bracket and add it
here yes it is working
so it is working so save it here and yes
we have 20 margin add a file create a
folder let me just change the button for
folder so if I come here we have all the
buttons here so let me
choose this outline but for
primary so if I CH if I check this we
have PN outline
for outlined
button so I can just pass it in
here and if I check it is now
outlined but the color is not properly
visible on black so I guess
what can we do if I come down sorry
success let me try this one called
success BTN
success so just add them it is now here
add a file add a folder so the thing is
this is looking good in here so why
don't I remove B primary add this here
remove this from here as well to have
have this button which is looking very
good we have add a file and uh create a
folder
functions so what should happen is if I
add a file the file should be outside
any folder that should be visible in the
like in the homepage so in the fire
store database we should have the
file like directly uploaded with the
link so so in order to upload a file we
need a function from fire store so if I
let me just initialize Firebase for now
because I have not done that so if I
just make a folder and Source called
Firebase config do
TSX and
now come to settings in the app project
settings come down let me install
Firebase let me just install this
meanwhile grab this things and paste it
here so we have to remove the comments
yes let me wait it for let let's wait
for it to finish meanwhile I can have a
sip of water H2O why it is taking so
much
time let me create two variables called
storage equals
to get
storage let me delete this first let me
boot get storage okay from Firebase SL
storage and the thing we have to import
is get storage I
guess now let me close this one not
collapse this close this so get
storage app by the way not export
storage export con storage it is a
variable that we have to export we have
to export this as well app now the third
thing we need is the database export
const database equals to get fire store
we need to import this as well I don't
know automatic Imports are not
working fired store no if I just add it
Firebase SL
storage and the thing is they should be
not storage sorry Firebase SL fired
store yes get fire store should be here
while we pass the credentials this
credentials now in the let's
say in the pages let me
import this
app or do we need to import it I don't
think we need to import it let me now
come to the server folder in the server
we have
dbts also
O.S so I don't think we need these
things
because we are not using Prisma so let
me create a file here
called fir store.
TSX let me close the
O let me close button interface upload
module
homepage or in here let me
import things from the Firebase config
file which is storage app and
database
import I mean import
storage from Firebase config also app
also what is the name of the database
instance it is
database so import these things
now we need a function here called
export const default just let me make
the function export
default uh what should we export const
let's say fire store this will take
request and
response sorry request comma response so
we need to add the type here so if I
check
db. we don't don't have anything in here
if I check
.ts we need to have like some
authentication things here like I mean
the what can we say the request and
response things
so it is not
here it is just for
o okay in the server we are having wait
a second server pages okay in the sorry
I'm doing it I think wrong this file
should be not should not be here because
it is for authentication only just come
to
API just come to
here still we don't have anything in
here so okay o i mean API let me make a
folder here called fir store.
TSX
TSX let me add the things here we need
to
have just
do
request let's say do
name thing is we have to add type of the
request so what can we do in that case
what will be the type of request or
response we need to import two things
here for the type of request and
response which is next API
request
comma next API response so in the the
next API request we have to add type for
the request and the response will be in
the place of R so the name does not
exist so we can just close it or remove
it we don't need to console this we just
need
to export the function
defaulty so we can say export
default this does not work like this so
we can remove export keyword from here
and at the bottom we can say
export
default fir store so let me just do a
RDS do status of
200 and Dot we can say
Json and we will return let's
say text as
hello
VA so if I just do in the browser Local
Host 3000 SL API slash this fire store
not fire at store I mean uh what can we
say what is the APR out here yes it is
fire at
store so we can say fire store we will
see the text are called hello world if I
zoom this you can see it as well so this
is how we can create API in XJ let me
come over to the this component called
upload
files let me make a function here called
upload file let me make a state here
called file set file equals to use State
use State we can have a object because
that's what we have the format of the
fight so if I click this button we can
have on click event
and we can simply set the file so it
will return us a param so we can simply
set event. Target it will add it now
this is inside the file we have to
destruct destructure this let's
say files okay one second in let files
equals to this file but if I just let me
just do a conso of this first one second
I am doing it wrong this should not work
like
this
because what should happen is if I click
the button we should open
a file choosing option
so we have to add that also let me add
an input in here
input and it will be type of file this
is what we have here do we have file
input types here so if I search input we
will have text input so if I search File
input we can have these things like we
can use them as
well so what should happen is if I click
add a file we should see one of
these let me get the jsx for this and it
place this we have choose a file but
this should should be let's say after
the button in here this will be only
visible when the or one or some state is
true so what we can do is create a state
here called uh is file visible
visible set
file visible equals to use state so it
should be
false now when we click the button
this
button this function or this yes this
function called set file visible will
turn to negation so on click we can just
do set file visible to negate this file
visible now we have doing we are doing
this here so we can just add this input
as a condition if this is true only show
the input else show nothing one
second what is wrong
input one
second this should have a question mark
here now it's fine click it it is
visible get again it is hidden now or
what we can do
is this yes so if I choose a file one
second what happened if I chose a file
we should run this function called
upload file so so one second when we do
on change here on
change in here this will just set the
file as event.
target. files
Z we can have event in here save again
this is causing some issues so we can
say as
string no I think not here outside no
will not
work what is the issue here if I hover
this it is
null so I think we should not use string
we should use an object no still not
fine possi it is
null okay set file if I remove files
from
here it is perfectly working so I guess
let me now
okay one second I think what we can do
is not have the set file in here just
have this upload file passing the event
at the top in the upload file
function now we can just restructure the
files from here so we can s let equals
to event. Target and here we can have
files the D structured property what we
can do this event we have to add type in
here
we can have files variable inside we can
store event. target. files. Z index now
let's check it up open the inspect
element if I just choose a file let me
choose any file in the folder called
photos let's say this file we're getting
its data successfully we have to send
this data to Firebase storage so to do
that what we can do is
create a
function basically we will not create
API for this because it is stough to
send a image through a response that we
can use in Firebase storage so basically
it's not tough it is I think impossible
so make a file or a folder here called
API in this we can make a file called
let's say file upload. TSX
let me grab this function or not a
function let me pick first let me make a
function called export
const file upload which will be an aror
function so we need these things from
fire
store not fire store Firebase so let me
import them at the top so we need
storage app and database basically I
think think we don't need database for
now so let me just grab these things add
them here okay we need to uncomment this
stuff so we need a file so we will get
the file from params so let me make the
file type as any here because who will
type this stuff and also this should
be console log of download URL fine now
we have to call this file upload
function here so we can just do import
file upload from this
route pass the files in here so when we
pass the files basically it is let's say
let make this as
file we pass a single file while we
choose
it okay let me close this so yes which
we will choose a file
here and it will come up in the console
after it gets uploaded so let me open
the console choose a file let me choose
this file here we are seeing the
percentage of the files 600 and then we
have the
ardl so as soon as we have the ardl we
can store that in the fire store so to
do that we need functions from fire
store so we can make fire store.
jsx sorry TSX not jsx in here let me
export a function export con we can say
add files which will be an aror function
so we can just do
import uh we can say
fire base no I think it is the database
from the Firebase config so we have this
let me also import a few things
called or which
are collection and add dog this thing
these two things so we have collection
and add dog so collection will be to
create a collection for our database so
we can select uh we can say files equals
to
collection and we will just just have
the database and the collection name so
collection is basically a table for our
data which is the files files table so
in the add files we can have ADD
doc then we have to pass files and our
data so our data will be image
link so we can say image link as image
link that we will get from from par so
we can just ructure it from here this
will be a
string to make it a string let me have
this in a try catch in order to avoid
errors so just let me cut this add it
here and have a cat
Block in order to have if we have issues
this will show up in the
console
err now we are going to add sorry we
have to call the function in the
function of file upload so let me import
it and by the way we don't need app and
database in here so remove them so yes
we need
import add files from
API I mean Pages slash one second yes I
think this is the one
API wait it's not in the pages so we
have to change it so at the rate SL API
SL
fired
store so okay this should
be uh not a default input now when we
file upload when the file upload
completes we will call the function
while passing this image link so it will
run and upload the image in the fire
store database so let me give it a try
add a file let me choose this let me
upload any file let's say this file
let me open the console for the
percentage it is opening I mean coming
here we have till 100 and now if I check
fire store we should see the image Link
in here for the image that we just
approached see we are getting it here
now the next thing we need is to like
add a blogas bar so let me go to on
design
again components sech for Progress we
can also come to dyy and search if do we
have any progress themed component here
so where do I search it here I guess so
progress I think yes we have it
so let me create a component for
progress in the common folder I don't
think we have installed art design so I
don't know why I opened it so so in the
common we can make a folder I
guess that will be for
progress in the progress let me make a
file called
index.
TSX and one for the module if we need so
we can say progress module. scss make a
functional component in here make this
as
common progress so we can let me choose
this green green one accent color let me
copy any one of the what is happening I
am not able to copy this let me copy the
entire block paste it basically we will
remove the others and we will have only
one the value is minimum which is zero
and the maximum is 100 let me just call
common
progress somewhere
here in the upload files so we have the
button and let me close this so let me
have it before or after this line of
choose a file so we can just have common
progress in
here yes we are seeing this but the
thing is the width is too big for this
so in this div let me have a Styles here
first so import styles
from this file progress. module. scss in
the div we can give it a class name of
stles do progress main copy this let me
come over here progress main this should
be width of let's say 80% or
something maybe
90 yes 90 is fine let me add a margin
top of 20 PX I think that that looks
fine to me so we need to hide the
progress initially so let me just create
a state for the
progress here
const
progress
set
progress equals to I mean you state say
zero initial
value we have to pass set progress to a
file upload function so pass it let me
come to file upload function get this
seter
function add the type as function now
this function of set press will be in
here when we are calculating our
progress so do that now we have the
progress now we need to hide this
progress
bar when it is zero so if it is zero
show nothing else show this to pass
progress for the value of the
progress so this
progress will come up here as
props and we can simply sign progress as
this so it is initially like zero so I
think we don't need to hide
it we can just have it here and see okay
it will be like this so basically hide
it all okay fine
so we need to add a prop type from the
interface so we can say let me come over
here and say
interface
progress so the progress prop is called
just the prog this will be a number now
we can just copy the prog interface and
add it in here like this now let me add
a file let's say this one
so we are seeing the progress bar which
means file is getting
uploaded and once it reaches 100 we have
to hide it so to hide it we
can just do
this what do we need to hide
it if I check so if it reaches 100 we
have to hide so we can say if progress
zero or progress equals to 100
it will be hidden automatically so we
can try this
again this
file it is getting
uploaded this looks cool by the way very
cool it's uploaded and the progress has
been hidden and we can see the image in
here
fine so the image is here the files were
uploading now we can show the files in
the homepage in here I mean so we can
close
progress come to upload
files one second no not here come to
home index we have upload files so we
can show it in here like make a
component here called or first let me
create
it in the component so let me make it
as show
files one index we need and one for
module CSS so we can say so files
dot module do
scss so make this a functional component
show files import the module of CSS or
scss import
styles from this file now let me import
this here so we can say show
files you will see this in here now we
need a function to get all the files so
we can make export
const get files we have the files in
here we need function
called on
Snapshot okay so basically I should not
have this here let me create a hook for
this a custom
H so because the on on Snapchat function
is not a API function we can just call
it in our client site so we can say use
or let's say
fetch we can say
files.
TSX here so just like we have it here we
can make a function to
export const
fch files which will be an aror function
in here we can have on Snapshot from
fire store we have to pass our reference
the reference is let's say the
files so we can just let me close the
files that we don't need like file
upload no we don't we we we need that
need that we don't need use session okay
we have to add it here as this we need
section one sec not here
sorry in here we need the files getting
passed in here you also need collection
from fire store so add
it this will take a second bam which is
a response and this database is not also
here so let me get it from Firebase
config let me also make a state here so
in I mean const say file list
set file
list equals to use State we can just
have an array okay we need a use effect
hook in here also so we cannot afford to
run it every time we Mount the component
we need to destroy this so we can return
on Snapshot and these things also let me
add the dependency array so we can call
fet files in the not file upload in this
file called show files
import
fetch files from
this so let me just let me close this as
well let me return something called like
this file list so we can just have let
file list equals to fetch
files fine it should be
empty so if I just console. log this
fetch files it will be empty because we
are not setting it the array is empty so
let me open the console if I
refresh we are getting a query
snapshot inside we have docs so let me
do response do docs then let me map
through this item can return let me D
structure the item. data and also have
an ID prop property mean I mean which is
the item. ID now we'll see the data in
here okay so if I just move this outside
let's see what happens it will still
work I don't know why it was not working
before but if it is working it's fine
set this in here set file list okay that
is the issue this is having an image
link and the ID in this State here so
make an object let me add image link
which is an UT string comma ID also an
UT string okay save this this should
work but it is not like what is the
issue here ID string this is not
assignable to set State action and blah
blah yes so what we can do is come to
interface make an interface here called
we can say array array type this we need
to make and and in here just set it to
UT so let me now come to this use
State have a cly bracket and add the
array type in here this will fix this
issue so the file list that we're
getting in here in the div let me make a
function for mapping so file L do map
say
file but it is still having an issue
array type does not have the
map this is difficult for me so let me
just proceed with this so you can say P
or not a p an image tag first make a div
and just have this like what is this an
image okay we need an image tag sorry
let me have an image tag from in here
from
Tailwind search for let's say
image we have Avatar no we don't need
Avatar we need picture if do we have
image I guess
not let me check no we don't have it so
basically just add an image source and
add file
dot what is the property image link now
gave this a class name of basically
styles do image link
like let me come to this show files
module so save this as well and we can
see the files but we are not yes we can
see the files here perfect now we need
height the same because we want to make
them as a square so make
200 and then object fit
contain not contain cover fine this will
be in squares like this images or
basically
files what about this issue property map
does not exist in type of array type so
if I come to interface add a map and
make it a
function what will happen Okay this is
working but I guess we need to add a
type in here as well so basically this
is an object so make it as an object
with the image Link in here I guess
so yes
perfect so we have done
this let me now come to or give this
Diva class name of we can say Styles dot
we can say we can say we can say
files grid so in here we can say files
grid display of grid grid template
columns Auto auto and auto to show three
in one row so we can make this as 300 I
guess let me also add the width here no
not width here should be add width width
should be 70% what about
this so we can just add a gap pile as
well 20 PX between
them okay not 20 let's say
30 let me increase the
with to
80% what about 90 no this will not work
basically we need to arrange them in a
center so we can just have specify
content Center okay we have to give the
width as 100
then now they are in the center fine
perfect if I add one more Auto it means
four Ino so this is the image that we
are having here
images but this should not be images
this should be like we should not see a
like a image here we have to make a
div so make a div with the class name of
files I mean this what is this styles do
files let me commment
this and let me style the files here
this should be height 300 and width 300
as
well background color
let's say accent or whatever this color
is so if I just come to what font no
this is the
font so so so we can we can have colors
here do we
yes we have BG accent so we can use this
so what is the code for this if I check
accent
color we have hsl then this
okay we don't have the color code for
this so we can just add them in here as
well so just do uh template lit and BG
accent let me wrap this entire thing in
in like a we can say template
literal make this as a like what is it
make this as a
string now let me have this and add
it in here now it will be working let
meit F font key so we don't need
background color here so remove it so
okay we are seeing this files with the
BG accent okay but if I add background
color as as let's say red this will be
visible so we're not seeing anything
because I think the color is not
matching with this so we can try BG
green
this let's see no not
working so I guess we need to add some
colors from our own
custom we can say like we have accent
color we need to have
the what I can say the background color
of this so accent
color code Tailwind okay we have this F
perfect
let me add a background color and add
this color here we are seeing this but
it is not like it's very bad so let me
just have Excel or accent black what is
this we just have accent or BG accent
let me try this one I think this is
fine now we need a we need one folder
link or file link here so so whenever we
click it yes so we need to make the cuts
pointer so yes whenever we click the
file or this link or this we can say the
card we should open the file in a new
tab or download it so let make the
Border as rounded so
border 10 PS not border border radius so
yes we need a rounded sorry not rounded
we need a part file what I'm
saying we need a
file icon so do we have icons in here no
I think we need to install some Library
so make
it let's say add react icons in here
simple save it so we need icon for file
so search it in here so we need we need
we need let's say we can add or use this
one AI file or AI fill file text
so come to show files import the icon
from react icons SL AI then render it
out here in this div now let me check we
are seeing the icon but it is very small
so make size as say 40 maybe 70 or
80 make it 80 it's not bigger now we
have to center it so in the styles.
files we can just do display of
flex justify content enter align items
now they are in the center it is in the
center correct yes so when we click any
file here we should be opening a new tab
with the link so the link is
simply this let me commment this file.
image link so make a function here const
open file
this will receive a let's
say we can say a parameter called
file
link which will be a
string we will use window.
open and string I mean this file link
and in a new tab so we can say what do
we have to open it a new it open it in a
new tab Target okay let me just
first hook this up with
the I with this diff so on click open
file and we need to pass this as a call
back with
the uh file. image link save it click it
yes so it is opening in the new tab
already so we don't to we don't need to
worry about that so it's working we can
also show the file name in here but we
don't have the file name in the fire
store so let me add it so we are saying
or we are sending the file to the file
upload so when second where are we okay
where are we doing this so we have files
in here file upload we are having here
okay add files it is taking downlo
URL where is ADD file it is here let me
add add image name so the image name we
have to pass from
somewhere so we have the files or the
file here let me just open it again the
file pro do
this so we have file so we can just also
share
file do name for the file
name so we have to get the name
here or we can say
image name as a
string then pass it here sa the both
files and we can try again let me just
delete the entire collection for now let
me create a
file this one it is getting uploaded and
once it is done you will see the file in
here now as I said that I am need to add
the name of this so that file was upload
files no show
files let me add a P tag and just
do this let me just check the we can
just
say file dot not image link the other
property which
was this image name so this image name
we have to D destructure from file as
well like the type like this so we will
see the name which is image this
jpg so we can align them properly first
so we are having the style of files okay
come over here we can just make FX
direction as
column let me also add gap of 30 or 20
PX Mine by the way this should be after
the image icon now it's perfect
if I open it it will open up in a new
window I mean a new tab in fire base I
mean in the Chrome browser so we have
the files here now what we have to do is
create
folders this is the folder that we are
having this button so we can have files
inside the
folder and we can have folders inside a
folder like nesting folders so that will
be a little tricky so so where is the
create folder button we have upload
files let me come to this we have the
button of okay we then this is common
progress yes this button is for create a
folder let me make a function called
upload folder which will be an arrow
function again upload folder will run
when we click the buttons on click load
folder so what do we need need to create
a folder in here so we just so we are
having the image link and image name in
here we can have this type of payload so
let me make payload
as folder name so we need the name of
the folder so when we create this we
should see input element or an input
element just like we are having this so
if I come
to this dazy Y and search for inputs
text input let me grab an input
like accent input grab this jsx do we
have input common file no let me create
it so or maybe just let me have it
here one second we are having an issue
let me comment this for
now commment this save this now add this
here
so we are having this name create folder
so we can type a folder name in here
maybe I need to make the width as say LG
I think the width is full so again we
need to show the input when we click
create a folder and we need to hide it
when we click it
again so we can have const is folder
visible
set folder
visible use State
mty let's say not empty basically a
false
value now this false will change when we
click the button so we have upload
folder the thing is we can't have this
here first let me just do a arrow
function call back function and set it
to negation if it is true it will be
false if it is false it will be true now
we need to just do if it is true show
the input else show
nothing now click create a folder it
will be showing up here and so on now we
need a state for the input value so we
can
say folder name set folder name equals
to use state mty so copy set folder name
let me come to this input and have an
onchange event this will take the event
as parameter event param and then we can
set event. target. value in here done
now this folder name will come up in the
payload of this upload folder and this
will when should we run the folder maybe
also create a button here to upload it
or to create it so let me have this in a
fragment let me have one more button
like this let me remove this or just
remove this yes and have this upload
folder function in here and just have
create make this as add a folder first
we have add a file and add a folder this
function or the button will create it
with the payload so we need the folder
name we have done this when it is
folder which
means is it a folder or a file so this
should be true because it is a folder we
need the file list inside it so we can
say empty array for now now we can add a
function in the fire store just like we
have add files let me replicate this
make this as
add folder let me gra this function fun
in here we have let me import add
folder and we can call this function in
here add
folder with passing the payload in here
so let me pass or get the payload which
will
be having this things called This is
having the folder name which is a
string then we have it folder aen value
then we have this one called called file
list which is an array save but we need
an object type not an array fine so we
need the folder name as folder name is
folder as this folder file list as file
list but the problem is we need to have
payload do folder
name payload do is folder and payload do
file list
fine so this is done we will simply call
the function and do these things in the
tri block
so one more thing I want to do is this
should be having one more we can say
prop which is is
folder this will be false because it is
not a folder it is a file FS e false so
let me create a
folder name this as uh watch should we
name it folder one click
create so we will have this folder here
so if I check we have the image and then
we have the folder file L is an empty
array folder name is the folder one so
now we have to come here not here in the
show files we need to we need to just
make a difference between these two
these things so by the way one second
and okay this is a AI fi file text so if
the file if the file dot what is the
name uh is
folder if it is true it means it is a
folder so in that case we need to show a
folder icon so let me open react
icons search for a folder icon here so
we are having an AI fill file text
similarly we can have
AI fill folder now we have to just
render it out let me give a colog okay
this should be also in here which is a
Boolean value so how do I type Boolean
let's say false this folder should have
the size of let's say 80
also
and we also need to do the same thing in
here so basically cut the file name add
it here with a fragment and just add the
same name here with a
fragment but the name of the folder here
will be like folder name not file name
so this should be that in there the
folder
name save this okay we have to also add
it in here also
empty now we'll see folder one and and
this one as the image so we have a fun
folder and one image we have now let me
just decrease size of the files it is
too big for us make it 200 this looks
perfect and by the way we don't need to
align them in the
center just leave this again not
here this should be not
Center this will then cause issues so we
need them on the left side so
why don't we make Auto
auto one more Auto one more Auto one
more Auto fine so this is the issue okay
1 second this should be 200 as I made it
before
fine so we need this on the left so we
can say align justify content Flex start
this will not have any margin on the
left so if I say margin 30 BX okay this
looks better
now then make Gap as 10 okay not working
so margin what about padding that will
come up in
this file so say padding 20 PX no maybe
just add them here yes this looks better
now and don't make it 20 make it 30 now
it's fine what about this one like we
can use it like this it this forend us
so we can say
repeat say 6 comma
Auto what about if I make it
to think that works like this or maybe
we can add Auto and then four no this is
properly yes I think that's
working let me make one more folder here
called folder two click
create okay this will be here so make it
seven so that we can have seven or let's
not make seven make it
six six item in one row so make folder
three
now then make four okay we don't have
the space for the six folder so make it
five let's see what happens this
will overload the page so basically make
it five in one row now now it's perfect
if we are doing this so we can remove
padding and make align items as Center
no maybe make
it supp content
Center yes now it works perfectly fine
so we have this kind of stuff okay we
have Gap okay okay make a margin top of
30 PX maybe not 30
60 yes that looks fine we have folder 1
to
five also we need to clear the input
when we create a
folder so we need to add a value prop
this should be equal to folder name add
it now we need to clear the set folder
name when we add a folder so we can just
do as a empty string let me add a six
folder folder six create it will be here
like so this is done yes we have all the
folders and file let me create a file
here one more thing that I want to do is
when we choose a file we need to clear
this as well like this input so I mean
not clear it hide it so in the upload
files when we do this like uh what is it
set folder visible to this so make this
as an function like this with where we
can have multiple things so set file
visible will be false when we click
this and when we click the file
button this is here this will turn the
folder visible to false so this is the
folder visable false in here we have
file visable to false now let me give it
right refresh click add a file now click
add a folder this will hide click click
add a file folder input will hide so let
me choose a file here let's say let me
choose some file in downloads
folder let's say my image like
this we are seeing the power of progress
and once it is finishes once it finishes
we will see the image in here we can
also
show the image here so like not have the
icon of the image just show the image
only so if it is a file we can just have
the image tag in here but we have to add
the styles of image link we can say
width 100 PX that's
perfect height 100 PX as well object fit
cover now this is a file so we can just
have border radius 10 pixels perfect we
have the images in here now if it is an
image now we have the facility to upload
files and folders now let's target how
to add nesting folders so if I add a
folder let's say folder one let's say
that we added it like a folder one we
can go in the folder and create one more
folder then we can go into that folder
that we just created and create another
folder inside that and the same is true
with files so first of all let me change
a few things here for example let me
make a folder here called folder one
click create it is here but if I click
it it will take us to the new page here
that we are targeting in here wait a
second it is in the show files in here
so if I click it it will just open the
file Link in the new window even if we
have no file links because in case in
case we have a folder we have to change
it so what we have to do we are having
this div here we have to just move it
inside the file is
folder like do this here let me remove
this fragment save one second I think
something is wrong okay we need to
remove this one as well so do this the
same thing like we can do in here
replace the
fragment with this div
fine so this one is we are having for
the folder so we will not do this so we
can just comment it out for now we'll
only open the link in the new tab if it
is a image not a folder so for a folder
what we have to do let me create a page
here that will be known as Pages sorry
not Pages folders We will make a dynamic
routing in nextjs so if I make this as
folder. TSX make it a functional
component name should be folder here
fine let me now return this in the show
files so
Import Show okay we don't need to return
sorry it's not a component it's a page
so we have to go to this route so if I
go to this route called SL
folder we will see folder text here
coming from this that is is a great
thing about nextjs it means or I mean
that we have the option to just create
pages and it will serve as a route we
don't need to create routes here so yes
so as I said when we click the folder
let's say this folder here we should be
on that page so we need something called
use okay it is use router yes correct
from next router let me create it
instance so
const router equals to next or not next
use
router see similar to what we have in
react so when we click this we should
just go to this file not file yes a file
that is
called folder so make folder here but
the thing is we need router. push I
think yes now if I click the folder we
will be on this folder page but the
thing is we need to pass a few extra
things as well that is called the ID of
this folder so let's say what I am
trying to say here is if I click the
folder we should be on this page with
the ID of the parent folder so if I am
creating a folder in here that means we
can only show those folder with the ID
of the parent folder so we will I will
explain it later it will make much more
sense so how to pass the ID here so we
can just change this to template
literals and just give a question mark
say ID equals to the actual ID that we
have to pass so the ID will
be file do ID is it file yes file.
ID so we have to also like add this in
the prop type or in the what is it map
okay one more thing let me do is if I
open the console we are seeing that ugly
message here let me show you this key
key thing so in this parent if make key
equals to five file do
ID save it so if I refresh this error
will go away now if I click the folder
one we having the ID here let me come to
folder and extract this ID so we can
import the same thing that we had which
is the router what is it use router
sorry use
router then let me just destructure or
yes get the router
equals to use
router if I do uh console. log of
router let's see what we see in the
console so we are having this object
which is having a thing called query so
this should be somewhere here this one
query so let me just get the
query and in the query we will have the
ID so also get it this ID fine let me
store this as a parent ID equals to now
we have the parent ID now let me change
a few things in the upload files for
example we have upload folder here we
can add a parent ID which will be so
this parent ID we will get from props so
let me get it so if we are on the
homepage let me just add it first and
comment it out so if we are on this
upload files let me show you if I just
console the pet ID and then if I just
come to folder let me call the upload
files component here because we need
that in here as well
so import upload files from component
upload files and then render it here
return it here so we have to pass the
parent ID so let me do that parent ID ID
will be equal to parent ID okay so if I
go to the back page the
homepage make a refresh so initially on
the Local Host 2000 the parent page the
basic homepage it is undefined but if I
open the folder we are seeing the ID of
the parent that is coming from the query
params from this top so we can use this
to Simply send the send the folder to
fire St so how can we do that so we are
calling the upload parent and if I
upload a folder they should send the
parent ID with the payload so if I open
upload folder function no add folder
function let me check it
out it is here so it is we need the like
we don't need file upload for now we
need where is it to have the parent ID
as a string
and then just add string as payload do
parent ID okay so we can try this let me
go back let me delete this folder from
fire store we are on this page Let's see
we are on where are we calling folder so
it is just a page fine we have index so
they are not
related we're only having folder as a
page nothing else correct
because that can cause some issues we
have we have add folder okay let me
trigger this okay yes we only have one
folder component not a component a page
so let me delete this one this folder
now let me add one folder on the
homepage let's say let me just do this
collapse that folder one let me click
create so we'll see that we we are
having this issue Firebase function at
Doc call in call with invalid data so we
have to fix that come to fired store or
not fired store come to where upload
files so we only send this parent ID
when this is here so we can just do a
pipe two pipes and make an empty string
so if this is if it's undefined we will
send this this string let's try it again
let's say folder one now click create
this is here reflecting in the database
as well the parent ID is empty string
now if I go into that folder and create
another folder let's say nested folder 1
we are seeing the ID of the parent which
is our something see this is the ID and
the same thing we're seeing here so
click
create it is here but we cannot see it
because we need to
like properly navigate I mean not
navigate we need to get it so we need to
just come to show files we are
having okay not show files one second is
is the current or the proper
component wait a
second we are having hook
which files yes I think here we have to
do the things so if I just do a console
log off here give it a refresh it is
undefined here okay is
it no something is wrong so on Snapchat
okay let me do one thing let me create a
function here called get folders now let
me just cut the function from here
remove return
statement add the get folders here and
yes one more thing we are having the
fetch files let me search where I be
calling this I returning this so it is
in here fetch files so this show files
should also take this parent ID it's
basically file dot okay let me just
search this fetch
files o one second no not here okay
fetch files this is here we need to just
have the ID I mean what is it item. ID
if it changes we will call we will call
get folder so file list let me check yes
that will work file list we're turning
here fine which okay show files yes this
is the thing we need so if you come
here let me this is missing the parent
ID which is the home component so
initially the upload files will have
parent ID as empty
string and this one also will be an
empty string let me now add show
files I mean add parent ID in show
files D structure it pass it along this
file list and if I do a console log of
parent ID in the show file Let me
refresh the page yes so I need to also
call the fetch data I mean fetch
component which is the let me see show
files so if I search show files we are
calling here with the upload files so
let me
close the things first let me start from
the beginning like what I have to do
here so we have the folder component
basically not a component a page where
we have top bar
upload files and show files so we are
calling show files with an
empty uh with is empty uh
property but here the parent ID will be
equal to this parent ID now it will work
like we also have to import show files
so Import Show files from component show
files we have done this now let me open
show files here show files to files this
one we are getting the parent ID from
here passing it further to fetch
files where is the fetch file hook we
are getting it here so if I click folder
one we are seeing the ID of the current
parent which is r h and so on if I go
back this will be empty if I click
folder one we will see the ID of this
parent like the next folder one should
be inside the folder on so if I check
the ID of folder one which is like r l h
and something it is the ID okay it's not
the ID of
this so one sec if I am in folder one
this is ID of yes it is the ID of this
if I am in NE folder one we are having n
i something yes so this is the ID of the
N folder one so let me do this one sec I
think it is wrong I guess we are having
parent ID one sec I think I'm passing
the wrong thing so if I come
to this upload
files no no no no no okay where is the
base of this this if I am
clicking this show files we are just
okay this should be not ID
should this be
ID I think
yes okay let's see how it
goes what we need now is we are having
the show file it is a little bit
confusing but fine open
the open
this PCH files hook so when it changes
the parent ID we will call get
folders now all we need to do is just
filter out our data from or using parent
ID so make it a string it is a string
that's
why
so first let me console so first of all
what we will do is
if parent ID is null we will simply show
all the like we will show this
thing the thing
is we will not like directly show it we
will have to filter as well so we can
say f
filter so show I mean show all the array
items if item. parent
ID is empty string so in this case in
the homepage we will see only folder one
because that is the thing only where the
parent ID is nothing or empty string if
I open this we will see nothing because
now it is not empty so here we can make
an L
block and in here we can simply just
copy this and add it here and here we
can say if the parent ID or item do
parent ID is equal to parent ID now in
here we will see n folder one if I open
this it will be nothing so now let me
explain this what is happening properly
so we are having folder one at the top
level with the ID
of EMP string in the parent ID field if
I click folder
one if I am if I click folder one again
we are seeing n folder one with the ID
of this one so the ID is of this parent
ID like this is the ID of the parent
that is why we are seeing this one here
if I open it we will see nothing
because because we don't have any folder
with the ID of this NH and so on which
is in the I mean here in the path param
so let me remove this console Lo from
here fine let me just
add as one
second as or just make this as any same
thing we can do in here so that the
warnings go away so refresh the page I
come so this is not having any files so
if we come back you will see nested
folder one let me create one more folder
here called
nested
folder okay sorry
folder two click create it is here so
let me make one more folder in the
folder one that will be called sub
nested sorry folder one let me click
create so it is here if I go back come
back to folder one we can see that here
but it will be not visible in the N
folder
to now let's work on the files here or
do we need to add any types in here no
we don't so let's work on the files so
if I
open
API fire store we are having add folder
we also having add file so this will
also have a a parent ID which is a
string let me just pass it
through in
here like this now let me see where are
we calling add
files so this
is here first so we have
to get the parent ID in here so parent
ID will be equal to let's say a string
the type of the thing will be string now
we need to see where are we calling file
up load so that we can pass the parent
ID here so we can just do
this let me also add the type of this as
a string but if I do as string will it
work no this does not work so we have to
create an interface come
to uh interface in the index we can say
interface folder structure parent ID
string let me just grab this come over
here and just announce this in here now
it is getting the parent
ID fine let me receive it here that we
are doing so we have to pass it here
like in the add files so add file
functions where is
it add
file
function we are having this in the fire
store here so yes we are now getting the
string as parent ID so we can try to
create this but I think we need to also
check the add files function where are
we calling it the file output
function so let me check we are calling
it
here with the parent
ID we're passing it here fine so I think
this will work so let's give it a try
let me go to homepage let me upload a
file here let's say this file 45 so it
is here in the homepage but the thing is
we are having the folder icon on the top
so we have to hide this so I think that
is an issue not an issue very minor
issue here also we are having this issue
is that says in upload files let me
check in the folder upload files
what is this
issue string is undefined is not
assignable to type of string so
basically it can be undefined so what we
got to do is come to
interface interface where is it and just
add this can be either a string or
undefined value one sec string string as
an array and utty okay this one add this
as
well one see second it is here yes
correct now it's the is not here so
close this so where where we we are
having the okay I think we are having
new issues this is a payload this is the
issue that I want to fix like if I open
interface let me remove these
things now okay let play it that fine no
problem so yes we have
remove this folder icon in show files we
are having this folder icon in both of
them so it is not needed so we can
remove this and by the way this parent
ID we are having we also need to add the
interface name which was
folder structure save it now let me okay
I think
this we have removed the folder icon
from the wrong place this should be here
correct we have the file in the folder
so click file it will open up in a new
window or a new tab now let me open the
folder one so we will not see any file
so let me add a file on this
level so we can just have let me just
add any file like this
file you will see this progress and soon
as we upload or it is uploaded the file
will be here click it it will open up in
a new tab now click folder one we have
no files choose a file in
here any file let's say this file wait
for some time and it will be uploaded it
is here see this image so it is in the
sub it is in the N folder
one it is not in the it is not in the N
folder tool open it we will see nothing
no folder or no files fine
that is how we handle nesting one more
thing we are having the top bar here
which should be in the pages folder as
well just like we have it in the home
component so where is the home
component yes so just let me have top
bar in here in folder at the top let me
put top bar if I now go to any nexted
folder top bar will be visible perfect
now what is this isue I am not getting
like this one type string is not
assignable to type of
string upload files let me open that
upload files what is it component
upload files component this is a string
so if I make this as a
string that will go away because now we
declaring that this is a string yes that
is how we can fix it fine now one more
thing I want to do is so we are having
all the folder and files in here that we
log out it will still see these things
so we have to hide them we cannot show
the files and folders if we logged out
so if I come to say AB do I mean index
we having home component let me open the
home
component so it's if the home component
is okay one sec we have this use session
let me search it we are calling this in
the top bar let me also call this in the
folder here import this use session from
this route so import it then what we
have to do check for session if it
exists show the image else sure
nothing so we can just do if
session is true return this save so okay
one sec top bar should be there as well
like let me just def this back we only
need to hide the top bar not no we we
only need to hide these things upload
files and show files so if session is
true it means we are logged in show this
else show nothing okay when is show here
we need to wrap this in a fragment this
should be here okay one second again
what is the issue save it okay let me
just
cut these things one
second what I am doing wrong here so if
f is true let me cut
this okay show this I think I added the
fragment this should be in here if it is
true so show all this stuff else show
nothing like can now sign up with GitHub
account and now we can see all the files
and
folders so this is done like this is how
we do it but but what about what if we
sign up with a different
account so in that case we have to
filter our data so let me just console
the session here so session is like this
object with the
user Ed object in
here so we are having the email as
well so let me grab the email so we need
the email somewhere like if I come to or
let me just use this hook in
here or what we can do is let me yes let
me go
to where are be getting all the data in
the show files here let me me just have
the hook in here let sh from use session
let me import them so to import them how
to import them just do this so we are
already having this P files here okay we
are having this so let me remove console
log from in here then now console log
will be in here the new console log if I
refresh you will see Nishant as44
gmail.com in
this so
files page or
component line number 11 yes but this is
not all we also need to send the email
when we create a file or folder so that
we know who is that owner so we can just
go
to upload
files here we can have one property
called user
email so the user email will be equal to
session. emails so let me also have them
here at the top level let me put the fet
session from the
hooks so this should be in here so let
me remove the console log and whenever
we add some property I mean whenever we
add some data we can have this so it can
be null so just add a question mark
after or before this so next thing is
add a question mark in here as well now
let me delete the entire collection here
that we start from the
beginning so delete this are we
recording yes we are recording so delete
this we'll have absolutely no files or
folders so let me go to the homepage we
are having the email on line number 11
in the upload no show files here
so let me create a folder here called
folder one click create it is here if I
check the fired store database we should
have the email in here as well the new
created email from the O okay it is not
here I think the thing is we need to do
some extra things with the payload so in
the add folder we are having this email
so let me add this user email now add
the user email as payload do user
email but I think it is
like redundant what we can just do is
just
pass the pay
load no no no no no like this yes then
we don't need these things remove them
it will be just an object so the entire
P will now go whatever we pass in here
it will go in the database no need to
just add this separately now let me
create one folder here
called folder one click create it is
here see and now it is having the user
email now let's filter it out so we are
having the session not user.
email we can just come to this file
map
here f. map it is rning this so we can
just okay one
second okay why don't we just use
session use the session in the fetch
function we fetching the data of the
pages or files so in the hooks we have
fetch files let me get it in here get
the use session from this route now we
have to just remove this let me okay it
is a so it is an email that is inside
the table so we can use
Query we can import query comma where
and let me create a param for
query so we can have
let query equals to or not query the
name will like Clash so we can
say email query query
what this will do is simply fetch all
the posts or not posts all the folder
and files with the name of or the email
of this so query let me pass the
instance which is files comma we can
have where like where is the conditional
operator here
where
user email comma double equals if it is
equal to this
uh session do user.
email this is done so if this is here we
can just pass it in both of the
snapshots not passing the file passing
this now if I see let me remove the
console log okay so let me not do this
let me have this like the session that
we are having let me have this in the
this file like show files so add this
here but add it before the file
list here now let me pass the session in
the use fetch files let me also import
the use session or use fetch session
from the parent like from here now we
are passing session so let me not pass
the session entirely let me pass only
this thing the user email from session
so let me
copy this here and paste it this will be
as a string as string save okay we also
have to get the user email in here so we
have to just do comma user
email which will be a
string now let me not have them here
remove this one save it
this will be replaced with the user
email now save
it now we will still see the error here
because this is sometimes not defined on
initial load so we have to put it in the
dependency array
here save give it ready flesh still it
is not here so what we have going to do
just we have to check if parent ID is
false or not or and because we need to
have both of them as true if user email
is true only then show data in here so
refresh still it is having some
issues so user
email we having in here let me just move
them in
here now let's see what happens email
query one
second I think this is wrong user email
should be equal to user Emil fine I
think what we have to do just move it
outside in a like just have it at the
top level of the function like if what
we can say if user ml exists exists only
then run this entire function so just
add them inside here now we will see no
issues we will having we are having
folder one let me me do something change
this user email to something else called
Nishant S
550 now we will not see the file or
folder here because it has not been
created using this user email like it
has been sry it is created using this
user email but it is not the same in
here that is why it is not getting
matched so let me add one more folder
here called folder 2 let me close
console
are we having any console logs no fine
perfect let me click create we have this
folder to as well now open folder two
this will be empty open folder one we
are having okay we are having nothing
here because it is containing no files
or folders so we can just add it let me
choose a file let's say this image it
will take some time because we are
having this progress bar perfect the
image will be here soon but it is not
one second let me check this
image okay yes the thing is we are also
having to we also need to add
the
image I mean the file email
link so we have to just do in this file
called fire store we are having
this add doc we are having basically
this is all the
files
so we can have user email as user email
let me D structure this I mean get this
from
props not props parameters which is a
string so where do we need to pass this
user email let me check where are we
calling add files it is in the so we
need the user email correct which will
be a string give it a comma in here pass
the user email in the ad file so that it
comes up here and it sets up in the
database now we need to show where are
we calling file Lo function it is here
so to get the user email we can simply
do this like session. user. email
session. user. email one issue we have
is a we can have a string here fine so
let me delete this file that we just
created let me create one more
file add a file choose a file let me
choose this file let it upload for
once once it's done this will show up
here with the new email it is in here
with the new email so let me check the
file this one it is having
the current user email let me add a
folder in here
called folder okay what is the folder
name of the parent it is folder one let
me add let's say nested folder two or
not two it is one create it so it will
be here now we can add any files inside
this folder let's say choose any file
let me
choose any file like this
it is here instantly upload it so if I
go back come to n folder one this file
will be
here let's create a share files or
folders feature with other users that we
have on drive so to do that let me add
Google authentication first using nextro
so if I come to the code here we need to
add our client secret from Google and ID
as well in the file so let me show you
how to get them open Google l in the
next.js
click developer console this is the link
of that click it so here we can create a
new
credential select client ID check the
application type as web application name
it so let me make it as Drive 2.0 your
name then we have to add our client URI
we have to add Javas orig which is Local
Host 3,000 in here so add it we have to
add redirect URL so if you check in here
if we are on production we have to add
the link with the domain name else we
have to add our Local Host 3,000 URL in
here so I am on local so let me add this
then simply click create here it will
create it so I have already done this
previously so if I open this we will
have a client ID in here and a client
secret that we can feed in the EnV file
so I have done that
already now we can close this come to
Google o so just like we had GAA
provider we have for Google so if I copy
the command
here add it in here the provider name
which is called Google then we need to
add the provider of Google in the array
of Provider which is scking the client
ID in secret and from M file this file
that I just added so this is the giab O
type or interface let me change this to
simple o o interface let me copy this
just add it here and add it in here as
well save it so we have no errors if I
come to the Drive 2.0 click sign up we
have Google option to sign up or sign in
so sign in with Google account so I have
done this for multiple users because on
GitHub I only have an account but on
Google I have two accounts so we can
simply check as we share files between
two users so let me log in with Nishant
as 44@gmail.com this email so we're
getting all these data because the email
is same now now let's add the function
for sharing the files and folders so
what we need to do add the dot using
react icons that it is very simple I
guess for you also so add it and when we
click it we will open up a modal in here
which is has which has the input
type input field two buttons share and
close on the button of share we are
running this function called get share
shared email so if I open the console if
I add the email say Nishant
440 at
gmail.com click hereare the email will
be here now we need one more State here
fault called current file ID Set current
ID as use State and empty
string now what should happen is if I
click the three dots in here that is
here we need to set the ID of the
current Post in that state so we can
just do Wrap This in a curly brace after
the window model opening we can say Set
current
ID as file. id file. id so the same
thing we can
do so this three dots we are having we
having in the folder and the file as
well
so we can add it in here as well where
okay we have added in the
file this is a folder yes this is a file
now save let me add it here so if you
don't know one more thing I have do I
have done this is when we CLI the folder
icon only then we will open the folder
not on the card because we have to
propagate this as well the three dots
function icon or the operation of that
so we have the ID now so we can just
console this current field current file
ID so folder two we have let me add the
email okay one more thing that I can do
is in the email property in that input
input property let me make this as an
email save add the email or also let me
add the value in here that will be email
save now if I
click also ID will be needed
email if I click the email share it the
email and the ID is here perfect now we
have to do what we have to do is come to
the get shared emails and run a function
to update the emails in the fire store
so we are having this let me just delete
this fields or start from the beginning
so let me delete the files now create
one file here before that let me show
you one thing so in the file store we
have add folder and add a file in here
in the add files we need to initialize
the document with a new array that will
be called as shared two that will be an
empty array initially the same thing we
can do in here as well so add it
save now if I add a file this this new
type of field will affect I mean it will
be here in the fire store
database so wait for it it is here let's
check now what do we have we have
files we have the share to array which
is initially utty if I click this share
button we should run a function to
update data in the file precisely share
to so we will have to add our email
inside this so let me make a function
called
export const share or
share file or folder so let me just name
this as share files it will work for
both of them this will take an email
comma so email will be a
string comma what else it will take the
ID the current ID of the file that is
current field also a string so let me
select a document first so let shared
file doc equals to Doc in here we can
just add the collection name which is
called
files we need to select the collection
using the ID which is the current field
ID because for only that post we have to
update but the thing is if I add a email
in here so let me use update doc
function so update doc this will take
this Shar
doc as the first Value First prop second
will be this email but the email will be
inside the shared to so let me copy this
field add it in here and just add the
email save remember that this is an
array but we are passing in uh what is
it a string so if I just do this let me
give it a refresh okay we have to hug
the function in here as well so import
share files share files from API fire
store let me run this function in here
we need to pass email and the current
field ID let me W it in a TR catch block
copy this add it in inside okay we need
the catch block as well
err CG error perfect no any errors will
be caught so let me share this one let
me add the email of my other
account this One Click Share now come
over here and the email is now inside
this one share to property but the thing
is we can have multiple emails inside it
that's why I chose an array so let me
get that array in here using get doc so
we can have get doc function
and by the way let me make the function
as
asynchronous because it is an API call
so
await get doc await update doc update I
mean get doc will take
the shared doc or shared file dock to
get data let me have a response in here
response equals to AIT get dog make a
console log here
here save if I just commment this now
come to the fire store sorry come to the
app Drive 2.0 clicks here we are getting
the data we need to filter it from here
so we can say response.
data save it click it again share we
need the share two so just get it here
the thing is it can be undefined so make
a question mark it will be fine so we
can do this again the last time and the
email is now here so if you remember or
I think you do we have made this as an
empty array so we need this
data D structure it and add our current
email which is this let me move console
log save so refresh the page so we are
having this shared email as this so let
me delete this field share it again so
let me add the email here Nishan
5@gmail.com
Click Share okay value is not iterable
okay the thing is what is the problem
here is it was a string so we can make
the field here as a or as an as an array
so add field this this this will be an
array click add now we have this now if
I just do it again it will work
share check here okay it is here let me
delete this one because we don't need an
empty property so we have this email now
let me type or let me share this to
another user called ud1 123@gmail.com
Click Share this will be in here after
the first email so we are having shared
emails
list now we have to get them for our
user as well so come to fetch files we
need to make a few changes in here so
first of all we need to
just have a check here so if item.
parent ID is empty when we don't have
parent ID in that case we need to check
if item do shared emails do includes our
user email that we're getting from the
par Rams it is if it is there show it
else okay we also don't need this email
query because we need not to check it we
need to just have files in here directly
not have the collection type of files or
collection name of files and then do
same thing in here with includes
so change okay let me just have this
here so change it change it here as well
in files now the second thing we need is
if I come to this and if I make this in
an cly bracket then add or operator we
need to check if item do user email is
equal to user email in case the email
that we are having is our own that was
the that is why we had the query
for the user email at the very beginning
that we removed using this query and
where
now same thing we can do in here for the
this one if the parent ID exists for
folders so save them it will work let me
remove the query and where let me
explain it again that what we're doing
in here so we are filtering here if
parent ID is equal to EMP string it
means show all the files and
folders okay we have this issue cannot
create properties of undef find reading
includes so let me just have and check
here for this and this save let F now so
yes where was I let me
explain this is the case or this was the
case for if the parent ID is empty it
means the root
folder else if the parent ID is equal to
parent ID show only those posts for
nested nested
folders now what we have to do second
check is if this is true and either one
of them is true and they are if our
email is inside this array it means it
is shared so this post that I having
this file I having it has been shared to
these two users so if my email that way
that I used to log in is inside this
CDLs array show it else or or I mean
show them when this user email is equal
to this user email in both cases if the
post is our own then the same thing
we're doing in here but this case is for
nesting so you have to get it fine now
let me show you sharing a post to other
user like we have shared this to Nishan
550 gmail.com let me create one more
let's say folder we can say let me
create two folders that first one will
be first one will be folder one click
create second one will be shared folder
click create they are both here let me
share the folder to some user called
Nishant s
55@gmail.com
now it is or it should be in here this
is for shared folder we have shared it
to to this
user so this post will be shown to
Nishant 440 and Nishan 550 or1 123
gmail.com so we can come
to sign up with the other
user this one we have wrong key here so
if item dot share 2 is equal to user
email then show it now it will be in
here so these two files this image and
share folder
are now shared to me so that is how we
create shared files and
folders so yes that is how we create a
Google Drive clone using next is